good morning learners we are here in
beautiful Vancouver in Canada and
attending the new Rip's conference 2019
of course one of the largest conferences
in machine-learning of the year it's
actually there's been a lottery system
for the tickets because so many people
wanted to register there over 8,000
people attending I think and it's Sunday
morning so even before the conference
starts I thought I was smart really
early to register but today is company
Expo day and I didn't register for that
because you know usually companies will
make fair bit of fuss about their
research online
so there's kind of little need to attend
that in person you can just catch up
later
but the everyone wants to get in on that
and it's it's crazy or like the line
starts so you go in here but actually
have to go downstairs and the lines
start somewhere like way back here on
the ground then you girl line all the
way queue all the way up there go there
over there up the escalator circle a
bunch of times go up some more I guess
then you maybe see people all the way
over there up until the registration
desks that are finally I guess over
there I didn't look but it's absolutely
crazy these conference is exploding with
people from all over the planet I don't
even know what kind of the composition
is I would be interested how many of
them are students of course machine
learning departments probably exploding
right now with people every company
wants to get in on that and I don't know
where the trend is going that growth
can't continue forever I feel and the
it's it's kind of questionable how long
we can uphold this how good this is I
don't know any of these things just try
to get back later going to work a bit
now get back later get my tickets and
then I hope I can report a bit from the
conference over the next few days I can
get some good nuggets out of there
that said I hope you're doing well
and I'll see you later but I